the gyro can experience so much mental
management involved in that that's why
when guys like Jaco come along and they
can take that understanding of
leadership and mental management and and
then teach it to other people yeah teach
it to corporations and teach it to
groups and yeah to law enforcement and
people that need that sort of
understanding that's coming from a guy
like cam with the immense amount of
experience that he has in a couple
different genres that allow him to then
teach that in a way that is
comprehendible and super efficient yeah
yeah it seems to me that that would be
one of the most important parts of that
of that job of how to handle deployment
how to handle coming back and the mental
aspect of it yeah do you learn it from
other guys like I thinks I think it's
just a I honestly think a lot of it is
that process weeds out so many dudes
that would be the the ticking time bomb
or the guy that can't handle it right
yet by the time we're training for this
stuff and it's super stressful
everybody's pretty much on on their [ __ ]
mm-hmm
you know and then there's like little
stuff that you learn while you're doing
shooting that you can transfer to all of
it the breathing techniques right and
then by and large we are so well trained
and know that we're so well trained that
you're just doing your damn job like
just do your job and do it the best you
can because I'm not thinking about me
necessarily as much as I'm thinking
about everybody else also that's
fascinating too that the training is so
ruthless and brutal that it weeds out
people can handle [ __ ] it [ __ ] works
they've been doing it basically the same
way since the 60s well hasn't there been
some chitchat about alleviating the
standards to let women pass through I've
heard of it I've heard I've heard that
they want to put females through the
program but not to change the standards
how many women have gone through buds
zero don't say that
women are gonna feel like you're a
success you should lie
I'm not sure can I gray area if how many
I would have tried me I did you not CGI
Jane cuz she went made through well yeah
but she's doing that Beltran special um
really no women have ever made it
through above night well and that's
that's a two-part equation there is one
there they weren't allowed to the entire
time I was in like there are females in
that when they start allowing them so I
I'm not sure but I think that they're
trying to make that a thing now try I
wonder how many women have attempted to
go through buds
Jamie's TV and Google how many women
have attempted to go through buds ladies
listening to this please don't get
uncomfortable we're not [ __ ] on you
I'm just trying to figure it out
yeah first one we made it through in
December well there you go what was the
screaming scream screening say that's a
pre-screening process oh so she only
made it through the screening how far
how long does that take I don't know
because we don't do the same stuff that
they're doing for that they're probably
making sure she can make it through the
program oh so they want to make sure
that she can probably a pre screen
screen well Jesus pre-screen they do
that they do that for officers to do
they really yeah they want those well
think about it mm-hmm bloods are shitty
enough now you're in charge of a bunch
of [ __ ] idiots right you're gonna get
[ __ ] on pretty bad right so they want to
make sure those dudes are on their game
mmm yeah yeah so where's the pressure to
make women do this is it coming from
women that want to do it or is it coming
from politicians that want a sort of
show that they have a diverse lineup
politicians 1% because here's the deal
I've met more than enough females that
are Apache pilots fighter pilots badass
EOD chicks which is explosive ordnance
like Hurt Locker right mm-hmm
there's some bad women in the military
yes they want no part of that job I
haven't met one that's like I wish I
could be a Navy SEAL and that's not it's
not [ __ ] on them they just don't
want that job why is that
alright you'd have to ask them but the
thing about Navy SEALs is that it's like
recognized that these are the best of
the best these are the most savage human
beings that we can create yeah the most
efficient the most effective the ones
that could handle the most the ones
get the job done when the [ __ ] is as
hairy as it gets
yeah and but why changed the program
just to diversify the lineup there's a
thing that they want to show right they
want to show that they're not sexist
this it's equal opportunity that and the
people that want to prove it are the
ones that aren't in the ring yeah that's
the problem right you're not getting
this from the the actual team itself
they're not saying you know we need his
chicks you're not getting pretty on this
place up yeah you know I think it'd be
great if we could just have like some
women running around you guys are pretty
ugly yeah it's probably gonna be really
weird when a woman actually does make it
through I'm sure you know I'm sure it's
the same like I feel for those women
yeah cuz they're gonna take a lot of
[ __ ] oh my god yeah but doesn't
everybody take [ __ ] yeah so like it's
extra [ __ ] extra [ __ ] yeah for sure
especially if you the first woman damn
right they're gonna be like oh well you
didn't do it the same as everybody else
which who knows right
[Applause]